three days felt like a month does it felt
so long great pass for gensel sends Crosby
and snapshot is fought off by Ingram
delay call against Arizona and there's
a productive sequence for Pittsburgh
early opportunity it's G Malin takes
it up top Carlson one timer block it aside by
Ingram he's Puck to P in takes it from Carlson
Crosby gensel shot score the Breakthrough
at long last a PPG for PGH in a pen strike
first tweaking different looks different
personnel and we see with sit over on that
other side on the flank as he rotates down below
P it in exchanges with him and what a shot what
a Play Jake gel look at the way he works off
that puck lead with 25 points on the year for
Arizona here's Keller Works around Carlson shot
off the outside of the net we talked about this
before kobby whips it around the wall a Tang up
on the play Down Low guden hands it off to Carter
Setter taken away by Arizona but not cleared
good work by this line is leang moves away from
pressure opens up rer is blocked and goes wide
Michael Caron up the Wall taken away by Carter
his pass out of the reach of L Tang into Center
gel right back in a goal already J gel shot is
stopped by Ingram it's Graves for leang cross ice
feed catches ell he'll RI it's wide knocked aside
by Ingram Marcus Pon does it again and back
back Ice come to pens it's Crosby looking for
a way cers Carlson shot stopped by Ingram what a
pass Sid was just waiting for that lane to open
up for Carlson play call here as the coyotes take
the puck coly bumped into for this Penguins team
here's melli seconde skater at an impressive
rookie year for the coyotes centering pass CR
scores and Arizona answers on a power play of
their own where tied at one well the coyotes
did a great job here on their power play of
spreading this kill starts up here at the
Blue Line see everyone just kind of gets sucked
right over to that side and that opens up the
middle of the ice for Krauss there's a good job
to find that seam find that lane bu stat at the
net just a nice shot tip play there to kuss
in front and they back to Carlson Taps it to
L Tang Marin needs L Tang thought shot puts it
back door get a Rob by Ingram and he covers wow
what a save by Conor Ingram off Jake gel who's
looking up to the heavens going Oh Me Oh My how
did I miss that see him slide right off here
he's so good in Calgary found a new life here
in Arizona here's Keller across back door jari
with the Poke check knocked it away from zooker
but he's going to be guilty of a trip someone
on the ice will have to serve that penalty as
Jansen Harkin comes over we take a look at it
right there really smart play by jari there a
good good passing play and there he comes
through and just chops a puck he gets the
puck Banks it to Keller tries to go up top
to Moser he'll slam it back down low that's
intercepted by Pon but taken by schaltz in front
Keller shot did ey by jari 45 seconds left in the
minor the jari being served by Jansen Harkins as
Jason zooker comes back in moves around Graves
centering pass cross right there he's blocked
rebound they score Matias melli pokes it in a
power play goal for Arizona they're second tonight
and it's 2-1 coyotes now and due to these power
play opportunities as we see how many times we
seen him do 10 and two just coming around but
it's ludvig he vacates the front of the net coming
in to help out right there possibly looking for a
big hit on zooker behind the net but that opens up
the front in these chances and machell jumps on it
see him there with the full visor on just kind of
banged around and then before that Colorado came
over in that nzm Cadre trade as kerfoot Smacks
it back to the line pinching is Moser taken away
Pens have a chance short handed Jeff Carter is
loose he's on go bander scar a shorty for Jeff
Carter we'll bring the dads right out
of their seats as the Wy veteran Jeff
Carter reaks in all alone just
a battle and some chaos along
the and stros a good work to take it away off the
faceoff win from Arizona and it's kessle ring back
in his own end his first goal turnover there
chance for in Str to stop Ingram then got aorn
is still loose and the Penguin couldn't finish her
foot knocked down clear to Center H estrosa after
the puck penguins have a two-on one hza with it
back head save made by Ingram Crosby connects to
O Conor across for leang on the backand centers
and it hit Moser it's still loose bounc it around
Ingram bounces on it still jousting away penguin's
trying to find it graves in escapes gets it lower
Sid that eventually worked itself over to leang
and then it was all hands on deck everyone's going
bodies down Ingram just laying on the ice trying
to get as big as he can and take everything away
there's no room for that puck to go you're trying
to elevate it Carlson just to think that next
step zahna back in with a step on kessle
ring centers in front Marin shots off the
bar how did that stay out great play by zah
Horna all that speed Patience by Malin just
H bounc it around so in tight back CER J
to stop and the rebound put wide at the
buzzer this line was swirling out there for the
coyotes cross ice for ell the Tang back
to ell one timer blocked by Moser Eller
gets it back carries down low 5 seconds on
the power play Smith rang he'll rip the FED
in Jeff Carter's got it again a PPG for
PGH and big Jeff Carter's put the pets in
front for this power play hasn't been able
to get it done well here to start the third
period another chance and Jeff Carter just
in front plants himself right in front of
Ingram the Penguins do a nice job of working it
around that second unit out there you can see
the tip from over above Ingram in the crease
and look at Carter he's melli turned over to
Pon up the wall it's going to come all the way
down gensel after it he's got a step on Moser
gensel leaves it for Malin tries to tuck
it it's in the penguin scar gel from his
chest that might be one of the most amazing
empty net goals you may see a power play
goal already and gensel has his legs going
doesn't he beats out out the icing and then
rest well they're going to make their dads happy
and they're going to make the 18,000 Plus
in the building happy a two-point party